[Music]
foreign
tatiana thank you for joining us at 20
minute leaders
i'm glad to be here thank you for the
invite of course so you know every time
i'm trying a different intro of how i
introduce the person so
we'll get feedback on how it was this
time but uh but it's fun to
try and do a talk show every day it's a
fun experience
i can only imagine okay
so tatiana and you know your bio speaks
for you
and and we shared it already let's just
dive into
healthcare and startups and i'd love you
to tell me a little bit about what it
means
to build companies in the health tech
space
and and then let's guide the discussion
towards you know kovit 19
and how are they dealing with this
unprecedented time of a pandemic
yeah thank you so um everyone knows that
healthcare industry
is not the easiest one to work with in
for startups it's been challenging
and i'm talking about the b2b side of
things that
you know it's not the most innovative
industry
and there are a lot of regulations uh
they have been
and there are a lot of uh hurdles you
need to go through
to work with large healthcare
organizations they're very conservative
very risk
adverse and so on so it hasn't been easy
and now
we have covered and and
so what's so what's what's even more
challenging now with covid
i think it's kind of uh from technology
point of view it's
good and bad at the same time meaning
that
carved kind of enabled
healthcare organizations to focus only
on the most critical things
so everything that was like nice to have
cool thing all those things have been
pushed
out no one has time so number one
priority
for every healthcare organization
is help us immediately today
to deal with this pandemic
and i think for
many different startups and healthcare
that became
you know some kind of challenging value
prop this
uh they have been providing a lot of
cool solutions but
for areas that uh right now
are not critical in healthcare right
and um and the whole health care
uh is moving right now rapidly to
telehealth and everything
you know so all those things kind of
impacted in terms of what
and how startups can should be doing
to work with healthcare today
as well yeah so i mean but you know not
all health tech startups are relevant
for kovid right i mean you have them on
all spectrums
so do you feel like there's a trend
across the industry to now
focus on how do we come up with
solutions for this pandemic
or are a lot of them just sort of you
know continuing what they're doing and
saying yeah well we're
we're just waiting for the day after the
pandemic to become relevant again
um first of all what i'm seeing from
our clients who are major healthcare
organizations
they uh they try to move as much of
they can online and
like we would be doing clinical trials
and build solutions that kind of
integrated digital technology plus
face-to-face
so now all of that is moving to
completely online you know so that's on
clinical trial side then um
we're working with um complex disease
management right
and now those type of solutions
uh to be able to provide
uh care coordination everything online
becomes more critical because
those specialists they're working from
home now they're distributed
they can't invite patients with crohn's
disease for example ibs ibd
to see them in face to pace and that
will be
going for a while right so
so there is a huge demand for
immediately available
solutions not just for coveted
but overall uh in uh
chronic disease management in critical
care and everything else
to kind of um help uh help our
healthcare organizations became
overwhelmed um yeah
is so our think is going do do you
expect the
this industry of or segment of clinical
trials
and you know research on medicine
and treatments to be moving more
digitally also
after covet or is this just you know
some mechanism
for them to adjust to the current time
being
i would say that wherever it's possible
to do everything online digitally
without
compromising the uh the uh
the the whole project i think those will
stay aligned
so i don't know exactly
if if uh if you're doing certain
compromises
on quality on outcomes whatever those
things are
then some of those things will either
be you know eventually public back to
where they were but if there are no
compromises i think they will stay
digital okay that makes sense so so
it sounds to me that you know a lot of
these a lot of these really
health focused companies that are not
necessarily
tech focused because they're now forced
to be moving online
this is this could just be beneficial
for them in the long run
because they have to adopt these cloud
technologies to be able to continue
operating
and now they're going to find that they
can operate more efficiently and at
scale is that is that a good assumption
yeah that's exactly what it is and i
think you know
this uh emergency kind of pushed
for certain types of innovations to move
forward faster
and there are a lot of new regulations
that kind of enable you to
do that because in the past you know
there are so many regulations that
yeah will not allow you to charge you
know like
for tele health visits and there are a
lot of
uh regulations that will prevent
patients to share
data now all of those are gone hopefully
for good
um you see what i mean so it became
easier
to do certain things that um were
difficult to do in the past so it's so
it's not
just the internal operations of the
companies it's also
how governments respond to this whole
industry
and perhaps you know lower removing some
of the walls and regulations that they
previously had
exactly yes yes yes that's fascinating
are there specific
are there specific interesting things
that you can think of that happen over
the past few weeks
that in the health tech space that
wouldn't have been able to happen
outside of this pandemic
again the uptick on telehealth that was
you know
was available as a service for a while
but have not been used as much as it
could have been used now with removing
all those
regulations and compensating uh
for evs it's the same way as you do for
in person that removes
tons of you know obstacles um there are
a lot of
you know real good developments in
having automated
um symptoms gatherings for different
wearable companies that have been
struggling in the past
suddenly became like very popular
exactly um uh yeah so a lot of things
have been moving
you know faster sure because of the
virus
so i'd like you know as a health tech
expert i'd love to get your input on on
this exact
issue so you know privacy in regards to
to health care and you know health
records are
are widely known as one of the most
sensitive records that a person could
have and now
when companies are even encouraged to
try and track more things
and you know i was joking with a friend
that a you know a possible response to
this
pandemic would be governments may want
to be able to monitor 24 7 your
your body temperature so that they can
track when the next pandemic
comes up you know i believe china forced
every citizen to report
on a daily basis their body temperature
so that they can analyze the trend
do i mean is this where we're headed
where
companies are tracking why a
a big group of people's um different
science body
signs i could tell you that from my
company point of view we released a
covet symptoms tracker
now it's available in english spanish
russian chinese and
hindi coming up in its free app and it
enables people to track
lots of data and share with a physician
so
we release it as a free app for people
to use
so they can you know from day they start
feeling bad
they can have you know all the
temperature all their coughs
all those symptoms logged in and share
with doctors
and to get advice before they go to er
now
what happened was we've been contacted
by large healthcare
providers and they saying now we're
prescribing this
pre-app for patients to use
before or you know from them they get
ill but also
as we discharge people we need them to
continue
tracking their symptoms so now suddenly
it became prescription grade
pre-app that we released who would have
thought to help
and we do this within like literally two
days
we put it out unbelievable
in we can integrate with wearable
devices and everything else but even at
the baseline
level it's highly valuable for
people but also for physicians because
now the
nurses they don't have to call after
appointment so how you feel
how's your favorite house because we
know that that's evolving for like
five six eight weeks after this
discharge so
uh it's unabandonedly became
very valuable app and
in the future of course we can integrate
with our wearables as we do for
commercial clients
but it was surprising to me to see how
valuable and simple solutions on the
tracking side can be
uh used you know yeah so i'd also love
to to hear a few sentences about what
what is it that you're doing
in your company and and how is that
integrated into healthtech and i'd also
love to
to hear a little bit about what it's
like being a you know
affiliated with a tedx bay area which is
one of the most prominent tedx events
around the world and i so i'd love to
hear
sort of both of these from your end uh
right so i started the company and
launched in 2015 at the white house them
a day that's where we launched and
we deal with the framework uh it's
highly sophisticated framework i love
you doug
oh yeah this is this is benny
cute hi billy um and it enables
rapid development rapid i mean days and
weeks of
highly sophisticated digital health
offerings
from chatbots to digital apps voice apps
and
um we have all those personalization
gamification
ai all those built-ins so we're working
with companies like mount sinai
oh wow kcsf ucla so all those big
companies in
enable them to create highly advanced
adapted personalized solutions
integrated with the back end physician
pacing with a friend and
everything in between for autism
cancer cardiovascular diseases
ibs ibd and so on right
uh and now this uh factor of being
rapidly create highly adapted
personalized white label things become
of value this you have a need
within days you can have your solution
so um so that's what we've been doing um
and um uh
of course you know uh we we're super
busy as you can imagine with all the
demands we have and i'm not complaining
um with that experience you know i built
uh that from day one of tedx yeah
literally was uh doing uh
salons like every week yeah large tedx
events uh once a year
however for the last few years i just
didn't have bandwidth running in the
company in doing that
so that's been on hold and eventually
when
everything you know settles i might do
either that or something similar to that
because people keep
asking me where are your salons where is
your tedx
so it's been i think the most valuable
thing
was that i met just incredible amazing
people
that i'm friends with all over the globe
that's the best value of tedx i'm sure
so so going back to
to health tech um i'd love to go a bit
a bit broader and and here you know over
the years what are some of the
transitions that you've seen
in the health tech space because you've
been there for quite some time
and so you know i'm i'm growing up in in
a generation that we take for granted
the fact that we have
all these wearable technologies and we
can monitor a lot of things and we can
just search online
and get all the answers to whatever
we're having but this wasn't a thing in
the past
and and i'd love to hear a little bit
about the transition that we went
through to get to this point
um if you if you look at the digital
health uh so the way i
look at things it was like phase
zero let's say you know from few years
ago
where every single large healthcare
organization
was okay it seems like we need to have
an
app right and there was this
wave of apps
like if you don't have an app and you
will look at the you know pages
of large healthcare organizations and
they're like
i know 20 30 50 links to different apps
right and i would say that was more like
oh they have it i need to have it they
have that you they have it and
my prediction at that time was that all
of that will go away
because we it it doesn't make sense from
sure healthcare organizations suddenly
they become software developers a
b you can't maintain
and integrate all those huge apps see
from a patient point of view lots of
people have
more than one condition at any point of
time
and if you can't tell them okay if you
have like let's say headache
you use this app but you have sonic aq
that app
so so all of that is
now uh normalizing the way i was
expected
to get normalized from both sides
so when you're saying normalize you mean
it's more consolidated
into you know single experiences where
that are trying to to encompass
a lot of different symptoms and
conditions
that that will be the third wave but at
least for now
is normalizing in terms of
why do we need yet another app how we
can
uh create smarter adaptive integrated
what i'm seeing on my end that there are
a lot of large healthcare organizations
that realize
the app on its own has a value but
limited value so
we develop highly advanced integrated
back end physician facing front end
with patient with wearable devices
integrated with hr
so you can see all of those things
coming as
one solution and then you can add
conditions to it
our framework enables for that but sure
i really
like that like we're working with
i don't want the name large children's
hospital
on a complex cardiovascular
solution for children so there is a back
end
physician facing complex care
coordination
across many different specialists where
they can assign
specific exercise target heart rate
everything
be patient to a teenager right for
example
it goes to the app that they see okay my
schedule for the day and you
eat that and whatever medication this is
an exercise
it's integrated with app that we built
on feedback
okay you see that so it's all as soon as
i'm getting hard
target heart rate here it goes to
physician dashboard they can see
monitor immediately all day back in so i
see
these type of things making more sense
in the long run
yeah no that makes a lot of sense to me
yeah right
so it all becomes like one integrated
uh authoring when it's personalized in
adaptive
it becomes even more useful a hundred
percent tatiana
i can 20 minutes went by way too fast
but before we finish
i i'd love to hear what you think are
three words that best describe you
risk taker visionary
and thinker i love it
tatiana thank you so much for the time
it was great thank you
it was great being here i have thanks
bye